It turns out there are many ways to specify a square. 1 solution with triangles
is a bit brute force. What you do is you create 2 triangles independent of each
other. So these four lines of code give you a triangle that goes from index 0,
1, and 2. These are the first 3 points, right here. And then you have a second
triangle 3, 4, and 5. That are these 3 points. Now you'll notice there's
duplication of points 2 and 3 and 5 and 0 and we can save space and time by
merging these. A more compact and efficient way to draw the square is to define
the 4 vertices needed and then define 2 triangle faces reusing these points. So
for example, here we're reusing these points, 0 and 2 for this first triangle,
and for this second triangle. It turns out that the 3JS library happens to
support a 4 point face. So you could just use one face like this. That said, the
way that web GL, DirectX, and other low level APIs work is to define only
triangles. When the 3JS library defines a 4 sided polygon this way, the
quadrilateral is rendered by 2 triangles being sent to the GPU. If you happen to
solve this exercise by drawing a single quadrilateral, that's great that you
read the 3JS documentation, bonus points for you. But it's worth your while to
try this exercise again using just triangles.